but let me begin by introducing gary
bernstein
my name is gary bernstein i'm running
for united states senate against chuck
schumer
this evening i have some fixed statement
usually i do this free hand but this is
so important for us to be so accurate
israel must continue to be one of the
united states most important strategic
allies on the globe
they are the key to a more advanced and
successful middle east policy
the obama administration's recent
wavering of support is
an unacceptable upfront to this critical
friendship and puts both americans and
israelis at great peril from the threats
of islamic fundamentalism
senator chuck schumer has simply failed
to use the necessary political muscle
required required to reverse the
strength
as the central intelligence agency's
former chief of hezbollah operations i
fought to dismantle one of the most
organization organized and dangerous
threats to israel and middle east peace
on a daily basis
after the attacks of 9 11 i was called
upon to act as the commander of cia's
paramilitary forces in the invasion of
afghanistan as well as by being the
architect of the battle of torah against
al-qaeda forces
these experiences bolstered my
recognition of the dangerous threats
facing both our nations
and the strength of israel as america's
key ally in the middle east
unlike many of the so-called leaders in
washington including my opponent chuck
schumer i will stand up and publicly
declare my unequivocal support for
israel and will influence our nation's
policies to reflect that position rather
than the middle of the road approach
that has gained so much support at back
rooms of washington and capitol hill
we cannot
we must not and i will not abandon
israel
a negative global response to recent
events such as israel's
2008-2009 military offensive against key
military targets after the exploration
of hamas's period of calm identified as
operation castle and the flotilla
incident highlighted the anti-israeli
sentiment that is gaining in the
popularity in the world and most
notably in the united nations
the u.n human rights commission alone
has criticized israel on 27 separate
occasions in resolutions that grant
effective impunity to dangerous
terrorist groups such as hamas hezbollah
and their state sponsors including syria
and iran
the world's growing anti-israeli
sentiment is as blatant as ever
the inception of the infamous goldstone
report is a clear-cut example of this
as dr danielle vordes senior vice
president of the shalom center said the
goldstone report is a way of using
international law as a means of saying
the jewish state should not have a right
to defend itself
i fully believe that israel has a right
to defend itself and that this is a
truth that should be paramount when
discussing and establishing our nation's
foreign policy
i insist that the united states separate
itself from the increasingly biased
international opinion and stand firmly
beside israel so that there is no
lingering doubt about our commitment to
her
rest assured i'll never play politics in
an attempt to push israel into any
situation that compromises her security
the united states must also continue to
enthusiastically deliver foreign aid to
israel while most recipients of usaid
fail to provide a return on the
investment aid to israel not only helps
protect an important strategic
ally it also helps protect america and
our troops abroad
i believe
talk about iran now
i believe that the existence of a
nuclear iran is the greatest present-day
threat to the stability and peace of the
middle east and especially to israel
accordingly i believe that it is
imperative that the united states stand
firmly and resolute
opposition to iran and its nuclear
ambitions
to date international sanctions have not
realized success nor have they been
taken seriously by iran
for instance resolution 1747 of 2007
gave economic incentives to stop
enriching uranium and resolution 1803
and 208 demanded that iran stop
enriching uranium however iran has not
been penalized because it claims it's
enriching uranium for peaceful purposes
thus rendering the resolution's move
is there a
is there a better word than pointless
for what the u.n un's doing to be fair
though the un is making some incremental
progress as demonstrated by the more
robust resolution 1929 on june 9th 2010.
while this resolution has more crippling
and serious sanctions iran still refuses
to cooperate and continues to build
their nuclear program
ahmadinejad himself called the 2010
sanctions
a used handkerchief fit for the dust bin
here at home passage of the
comprehensive iran sanctions
accountability and disinvestment act
which is called sisada provided more
teeth to the old to the already in place
un sanctions in fact according to the
american israeli public affairs
committee aid bank the results of sita
sisa that have been positive and
significant to include france has
announced it would no longer provide
patrolling to iran and lloyds of london
announced it would restrict insurance to
vessels shipping patrolling to iran this
is good our european friends is finally
helping us today
i believe that in order to ensure a
nuclear-free iran the obama
administration must continue to strictly
enforce csida and the united states and
the u.n security council must cooperate
in pursuit of even stronger and more
aggressive international sanctions
regardless of these developments i am
mindful of the seismic geopolitical
shift that would occur should iran
achieve nuclear ambitions
this development cast a dangerous shadow
over any hopes of a lasting peace for
the region and beyond
this is why i believe that the threat
must ultimately derail by any means
necessary and that military action must
remain on the table
i believe that israel should continue to
aggressively explore peaceful solutions
to the ongoing land and political
dispute with its neighbors
but any such negotiations must be
initiated without undue exterior
pressure from the u.s or the world
community because ultimately it must be
a negotiated settlement that is in the
best interest of both sides
if not any publicized gains will once
again be short-lived
with two separate pallets with two
separate palestinian entities and gaz in
the west bank
the already challenging proposals for
peace are made even more difficult
i believe israel should not negotiate
with hamas or any terrorist group until
at a minimum they recognize israel's
right to escape
i am committed to ensuring the current
policy of the united states that holds
aid to hamas excuse me
i am committed to ensuring that the
current policy of the united states that
holds all aid to hamas be halted until
that record until they recognize
israel's right to exist
ultimately there should be a jewish
state and an arab state living side by
side perhaps when the palestinian
authority realizes that when they
denounce and fight terrorism a
palestinian state alongside an israeli
state
the us and our policy in the middle east
we've had no policy on iran
and the key to all of this is we must
have a policy on iran that demands
regime change
not negotiations
but we need to support a radio free
europe-type entity and others we need to
work to remove those molds
i'd like to take the two questions now
military ability to set bank the iranian
nuclear program
the important point to understand is
this
on the military side if you're going to
do a military strike
you need to set them back about ten
years and not two years that's that's
the important point if you're going to
do this militarily you got to send back
10 years that means you have to hit a
lot of those facilities israel does have
the technology for
deep earth penetrating devices as the
united states has
the israelis you know we talked in the
united states uh about drones you know
we have the predator we have the reaper
now the reaper is the biggest one we
have it's the size of an f-16 the
israelis recently unveiled their newest
drone it's the size of a 737 guess what
that's cool
probably the program but anyway i was
only have to take two questions
that's it i want to thank you all
you